some people are opening their eyes
and even people who were democrats for
their whole life even people who were
professionally Democrats even people who
ran for president in the Democrat
primary and then dropped out and
endorsed the Democrat nominee Joe Biden
even they are waking up and they are
leaving the Democrat Party
namely Tulsi gabbard
I can no longer remain in today's
Democratic party that's under the
complete control of an elitist cabal of
warmongers who were driven by cowardly
wokeness who divide Us by racializing
every issue and stoking anti-white
racism who actively worked to undermine
our god-given freedoms that are
enshrined in our constitution who are
hostile to people of faith and
spirituality who demonize the police but
protect criminals at the expense of
law-abiding Americans who believe in
open borders who weaponize the National
Security State to go after their
political opponents and above all who
are dragging us ever closer to nuclear
war
now I believe in a government that's of
the People by the people and for the
people
unfortunately today's Democratic party
does not instead it stands for a
government that is of by and for the
powerful Elite
now I'm calling on my fellow Common
Sense independent-minded Democrats to
join me in leaving the Democratic Party
if you can no longer stomach the
direction that the so-called woke
Democratic party ideologues are taking
our country
and I invite you to join me
she is 100
correct every word she said every
syllable she said is correct
there's no but there's no but I I often
do not focus on the stories of
so-and-so's leaving the left or the
liberals or the Democrats or whatever
because I just think okay yeah we always
cheer when some lib you know is no
longer comfortable in Democrat party and
we make a big to do out of it but
usually the person remains fairly
liberal
or vice versa you know some liberal
Republican finally says okay I hate
these conservatives I'm thinking of Adam
Kinsey or Liz Cheney or whatever but
some big lib who pretends to be a
republican says okay I'm not going to be
a republican anymore and all of a sudden
the libs cheer and they they go crazy
and they make a big to do out of it I
think it's often disingenuous
but what we're seeing here from Tulsi
gabbard is something
genuinely novel
you don't get the impression
listening to that
that she while she was just mistaken to
be a Democrat come on Tulsi you know
you're just see you're a republican you
just don't know it yet no that's not you
don't get that feeling you get the
feeling that she could have fit into the
Democratic party maybe at some point but
there were always things that were a
little different I think Tulsi gabbard
genuinely isn't independent
the thing she's talking about there are
kind of edgy she's calling out
anti-white racism that's the sort of
thing that you really are not permitted
to call out in either party
certainly not until very very recently
you were not allowed to call that out
she's calling out warmongers in both
parties again this is the sort of thing
that you're you're not really allowed to
talk about right now the Democrats are
absolutely belligerent over the war in
Ukraine they're they're they seem
bloodthirsty for for a more direct
confrontation with Russia that's
certainly been the effect of what the
administration has done that's what
she's calling out she's totally right
and Republicans are kind of mixed on it
Republicans certainly during the bush
era and since then they've kind of just
gone along with the National Security
State
speaking of the National Security State
she's calling out the government spying
on us
neither party really calls that out
they're Republicans cheered it on
as especially during the bush era the
National Security state began to take
more and more power to spy on civilians
the Republicans were totally fine with
that and now the Democrats are the one
wielding that power the Democrats are
the ones who wield the IC and all of
those surveillance powers to spy on the
Trump campaign to undermine the
Republican nominee for president to
undermine his administration to go after
ordinary conservatives
to attack not just Trump you know and to
to knock down the door of Mar-A-Lago
practically
because because Donald Trump is the
chief political rival to Joe Biden but
to go after parents who say we don't
want our kids to be taught weird stuff
in schools to go after ordinary
conservatives who who are now maligned
as insurrectionists and terrorists and
far-right semi-fascists
so you can't really call it out an
either party Tulsi gabbard is actually
just kind of opening her eyes up to the
problem of the liberal blob the liberal
establishment
that is pushed by the left and that is
largely tolerated by the right so I
cheer her on I have no but here I
suspect she and I disagree on certain
issues that she did not bring up in that
video
but in that video in her Declaration of
why she's leaving the Democrat Party she
expresses a clearer view of political
reality than every Democrat and then
most Republicans incredible stuff I
cheer her on and frankly I think what
you're going to see and you're already
beginning to see this the Trump movement
I think was fairly representative of
this
you're going to see a kind of third
force in politics emerge
that that really sees
far greater similarity between the
establishment Republicans and the
Democrats than difference they're going
to say that the Republican Democrat game
that we've seen certainly for the last
20 30 years is is really just kind of
two sides of the same coin it's a kind
of sock puppet battle where whichever
party wins the problems that really
matter to Americans are going to get
worse whichever party wins immigration
is going to become more and more of a
problem whichever party wins the
hollowing out of American manufacturing
is going to get worse and worse
whichever party wins the foreign policy
is just going to be the same old swampy
stuff that's been conducted since the
end of the Cold War and they're going to
see this seems like kind of a rigged
game and you're going to see more
independent thinkers whether or not that
can coalesce into a cohesive political
movement that remains to be seen But
Tulsi gabbard has taken a huge step in
that direction the rest of the show is
continuing now in the members block it
is woke Wednesday and so my producer Ben
Davies has teed up a new challenge for
me it is from the channel love don't
judge and the challenges to see how long
I can just totally simply merely love
without any kind of judgments whatsoever
creeping into my head I'm not sure how
long I'm going to make it if you are not
a member click the link in the
description and join us we will see you
on the member block
[Music]
[Music]